I believe critics are right to point out
that without proper safeguards this type
of program could be used to yield more
information about our private lives and
open the door to more intrusive bulk
collection programs in the future
they're also right to point out that
although the telephone bulk collection
program was subject to oversight by the
foreign intelligence surveillance court
and has been reauthorized repeatedly by
Congress it has never been subject to
vigorous public debate for all these
reasons I believe we need a new approach
I am therefore ordering a transition
that will end the section 215 bulk
metadata program as it currently exists
and establish a mechanism that preserves
the capabilities we need without the
government holding this bulk metadata
this will not be simple the review group
recommended that our current approach be
replaced by one in which the providers
or a third party retain the bulk records
with government accessing information as
needed both of these options pose
difficult problems relying solely on the
records of multiple providers for
example could require companies to alter
their procedures in ways that raise new
privacy concerns on the other hand any
third-party maintaining a single
consolidated database would be carrying
out what's essentially a government
function but with more expense more
legal ambiguity potentially less
accountability all of which would have a
doubtful impact on increasing public
confidence that their privacy is being
protected during the review process some
suggested that we may also be able to
preserve the capabilities we need
through a combination of existing
authorities better information sharing
and recent technological advances but
more work needs to be done to determine
exactly how this system might work
because of the challenges involved I've
ordered that the transition away from
the existing program will proceed in two
steps effective immediately we will only
pursue phone calls that are two steps
removed from a number associated with
the terrorist organization instead of
the current three and I have directed
the Attorney General to work with the
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Court
so that during this transition period
the database can be queried only after a
judicial finding or in the case of a
true emergency